[Musique]
un vélo chopper customiser ans de
dosches c'est le tout dernier modèle
sorti de l'atelier de jérémy levier de
vitesse phares jusqu'à la de
betty chaque accessoire fleure bon la
tâche vos bouchons de réservoir de nos
shows avec une clé pour changer la roue
au cas où qu'on crève feux arrière de
deux chevaux
là on a le levier de vitesses de deux
chevaux qui passe vraiment les vitesses
sont là sont le moyen à l'arrière ne
trouvant pas vélo à son pied le
carrossier de métier s'est lancé dans le
sur mesure
il y passe même tous ses loisirs le vélo
de deux lui a demandé six mois de
travail comme les ailes étaient vraiment
très pourri à la base ça me prend
beaucoup de temps à restaurer à à
refaire des morceaux d'elle pour que ça
en vraiment dedans et puis les tout ce
qui va être moulures oui et tout ce qui
est mou leurs deux cadres d'elle tout ça
c'était quand même assez compliqué à
faire mais oui la finition prennent
beaucoup de temps postés sur les réseaux
sociaux le bicycle rétro a rencontré son
public
ça a pris 81,80 mille vue sur la page
sas est dispatché un peu partout dans le
monde quoi donc y en a en fait des
photos en chine en espagne sur les plus
gros sites c'est assez marrant c'est
parti vraiment partout aux états-unis
aussi un peu partout
jérémy et son équipe sont déjà en route
pour réaliser un cinquième modèle un
vélo joker qui devrait révéler de bien
belles surprises